vamos a resolver este problema nos
preguntan esta figura qué tipo de
cuadrilátero es y aquí nos dan algunas
opciones vamos a ver será un rombo bueno
pues para que sea rombo debe tener sus
cuatro lados iguales y en efecto los
tiene verdad todos miden diez entonces
la figura es un rombo será un
paralelogramo pues aquí marcan que este
lado es paralelo a este y que este lado
es paralelo a este entonces si es un
paralelogramo porque sus pares de lados
opuestos son paralelos será un cuadrado
pues para que sea cuadrado necesitamos
que sus ángulos sean de 90 grados y que
todos sus lados me dan lo mismo los
lados y miden lo mismo pero los ángulos
no son de 90 grados así que no no es un
cuadrado y por la misma razón tampoco
puede ser un rectángulo entonces solo
esas dos son las correctas
muy bien la siguiente pregunta vamos a
resolver este problema el cuadrilátero
jd es un paralelogramo cuáles
proposiciones deben ser verdaderas bueno
pues vamos a ver qué opciones nos dan
los cuatro lados de jota a de jade son
iguales no estoy aquí no tiene por qué
ser correcta verdad solo sabemos que es
un paralelogramo que tiene lados
opuestos paralelos entonces están los
cuatro ángulos de jade son iguales no
tampoco jade tiene dos pares de lados
opuestos paralelos si justo esta es la
definición de que sea un paralelogramo
muy bien siguiente pregunta vamos a ver
nos dice que el cuadrilátero o n y x el
cuadrilátero o nicks es un rombo y nos
preguntan cuáles proposiciones deben ser
verdaderas bueno pues para que un
cuadrilátero sea un rombo necesitamos
que sus cuatro lados sean iguales eso es
la primera opción
luego nos dice los cuatro lados los
cuatro ángulos de ónix son iguales no o
nicks tiene dos pares de lados opuestos
para
esta de aquí sí es cierta porque
recuerda que en un rombo tenemos que
también los pares de lados opuestos son
paralelos un rombo es un paralelogramo
aunque un paralelogramo no
necesariamente sea un rombo entonces
estas dos son las opciones correctas
muy bien